>>> WHO JUST TAPPED INTO THE
"GROUP CHAT" LIVE IN THE
"BLEACHER REPORT" APP PRESENTED
BY FANDUEL.
I'M GREG IVORY ALONGSIDE THE
LOVELY ERIN DOLAN.
>> YES.
>> TONIGHT IS GAME FIVE IN THE
BUCKS/HAWKS SERIES.
CABBIE IS STILL ON PTO.
>> I'M JEALOUS OF CABBIE.
I WOULDN'T MIND BEING AT THE
BEACH ALL WEEK WITH THE HOLIDAY
COMING UP.
>> IT WAS A HEAT WAVE ON THE
EAST COAST, THE BEACH DOES SOUND
NICE.
WE HAVE HOODIES TO GIVE AWAY,
NBA JERSEYS TO GIVE AWAY.
THE FIRST ONE WILL GO OUT --
WHEN SHOULD WE GIVE IT OUT?
>> HOW ABOUT NOW?
>> ALL RIGHT.
PEOPLE NEW TO THE SHOW, TO THIS
THING RIGHT HERE, ERIN, WOULD
YOU TELL THEM WHAT THIS IS?
>> THE HANDY DANDY iPAD.
>> THIS IS THE HANDY DANDY iPAD.
THIS IS HOW YOU GET YOUR JERSEY.
THIS IS HOW YOU GET YOUR
HOODIES.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I HAVE C4SH SAYS MIDDLETON
DOUBLE-DOUBLE, BUCKS TO WIN.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
I DON'T THINK I'LL GIVE YOU THE
HOODIE FOR THAT.
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT.
I'M STILL IN THE COMMENTS.
I SEE HALISE 6 SAYS IF TRAE
YOUNG DOESN'T PLAY, LOU WILLIAMS
IS MY BEST BET.
HE DROPPED 21 POINTS AND IS
DROPPING 36 TONIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
GUESS WHAT?
HE REPEATED HIS COMMENT FOUR,
FIVE TIMES.
I'M NOT GIVING YOU THE JERSEY
FOR THAT.
THE NEXT PERSON IS GETTING THE
JERSEY.
I PROMISE YOU.
LAST TIME WE'RE IN THE COMMENTS
FOR THIS JERSEY.
>> PEOPLE ARE OUT OF THEIR
SEATS, GREG.
>> I HAVE -- HOLD ON.
HERE WE GO.
I GOT MY GUY, NOT RONALD ACUNA
JR.
HE WON A LOT OF HOODIES, NOT A
JERSEY.
HE SAID MIDDLETON SCORING 34.
CAPELA WITH 20 PLUS REBOUNDS
TONIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
JERSEY.
LET'S GET TO THIS FIRST SEGMENT.
AS YOU KNOW, FANDUEL IS RUNNING
OUR FAVORITE BET, ERIN.
THE 3x2.
FOR EVERY GAME THE REST OF THE
PLAYOFFS.
TONIGHT THE ATLANTA/MILWAUKEE
3x2 IS -- I THINK IT'S UP AROUND
150.
THOSE ARE GOOD ODDS.
I NEED EVERYBODY IN THE
COMMENTS, TUNING IN, GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME IF YOU
THINK THE 3x2 WILL HIT TONIGHT.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE, ERIN?
>> I KNOW SOME BETTORS WERE
FRUSTRATED AFTER THE LAST "GROUP
CHAT" SHOW SAYING YOU JUST HAVE
TO TAKE IT WHEN THEY OFFER THE
3x2, SORRY TO UPSET YOU AGAIN,
BUT YOU JUST HAVE TO TAKE IT.
AFTER THE BUCKS SHOT A 21% FROM
THREE-POINT RANGE IN GAME FOUR,
I THINK WE'LL SEE POSITIVE
REGRESSION THERE.
JUST TAKE THE 3x2.
>> ERIN, SEE WHAT YOU DID THERE?
YOU PUT YOUR FOOT DOWN.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> I LIKE WHEN YOU PUT YOUR FOOT
DOWN.
YOU STOOD ON YOUR WORD.
YOU WERE STANDING BY THE 3x2 NO
MATTER WHAT.
I LOVE THAT.
I LOVE THAT, THAT'S WHAT I DO.
I RIDE BY THE 3x2 NO MATTER WHAT
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN WHAT VIBES?
>> THE GOOD VIBES?
THE SUNSET VIBES?
STILL SUNSET?
>> SUNSET AND GOOD VIBES BOTH GO
ALONG.
>> THEY COINCIDE.
>> YEAH.
THEY'RE LIKE THE SAME THING.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
THE PEOPLE ARE HERE FOR HOODIES.
THEY WANT HOODIES.
I'M HERE TO GIVE AWAY HOODIES.
I HAVE HJ HAZEN SAYS THE 3x2
WILL CASH TONIGHT.
NO DOUBT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, HJ HAZEN.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I HAVE ONE MORE.
LAN
LANCE-ALICIOUS.
>> WHAT A NAME.
YOU KNOW THE HOMEY P.J. TUCKER
WILL GO BEAST MODE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
MY GUY P.J. TUCKER DOES LIKE TO
SHOW THE CLAMPS ON DEFENSE.
I WILL GIVE AWAY ONE MORE
HOODIE.
THE COMMENTS ARE JUMPING TODAY.
>> LOVE IT.
>> I HAVE TO ACTUALLY PRESS THE
COMMENTS IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
STOP BECAUSE THEY'RE JUMPING SO
MUCH.
JASON WADE 13, HE SAYS JRUE
HOLIDAY HAS A GREAT GAME.
HE'S CALLING IT NOW.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, JASON WADE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
LIKE ERIN JUST SAID, HE NEEDS TO
HAVE A GOOD GAME.
NO GIANNIS TONIGHT.
NO GIANNIS.
SPEAKING OF NO GIANNIS, WHO IS
THE MORE VALUABLE PLAYER TO
LOSE?
TRAE OR GIANNIS?
THIS HAS BEEN A CRAZY SERIES.
TRAE IS QUESTIONABLE.
GIANNIS IS OFFICIALLY OUT.
WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO IN
THE COMMENTS, GET IN THE
COMMENTS, TELL ME WHICH OF THESE
PLAYERS IS MORE VALUABLE?
IS TRAE A BIGGER LOSS TO THE
HAWKS OR IS GIANNIS A BIGGER
LOSS TO THE BUCKS AND TELL ME
WHY.
PLEASE TELL ME WHY.
THE BEST TAKE IS GETTING THE
JERSEY.
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED WITH THESE
TWO IN GAME FOUR.
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED.
GIANNIS, THAT WAS A SURPRISE.
WE DID NOT SEE THAT HAPPENING.
NOW THAT MILWAUKEE HAS SOME TIME
TO PLAN, WHAT DO YOU THINK FOR
TONIGHT?
>> CONSIDERING ATLANTA WON GAME
FOUR WITHOUT TRAE YOUNG, I WOULD
SAY GIANNIS IS THE MORE VALUABLE
PLAYER TO LOSE.
AFTER HE LEFT IN THE LAST GAME,
THE HAWKS WENT ON A 25-10 RUN.
THAT SHOWS US HOW QUICKLY THAT
TEAM DISCOMBOBULATED AFTER
GIANNIS WAS NOT ON THE FLOOR.
JRUE HOLIDAY AND KHRIS MIDDLETON
NEEDED TO STEP UP.
GIANNIS IS RULED OUT FOR THIS
GAME.
CONSIDERING THE HAWKS WON GAME
FOUR WITHOUT TRAE AND GIANNIS
SUFFERED AN INJURY IN THE THIRD
QUARTER, WITH THE GREEK FREAK
BEING OUT HE WILL BE THE MOST
VALUABLE PLAYER TO LOSE IN THE
SERIES.
>> I LOVE THAT TAKE.
I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH YOU.
WE SAW IT.
WE SAW IT IN GAME FOUR.
THE HAWKS, THEY'RE VERY LUCKY --
LUCKY TO HAVE A BACKUP LIKE LOU
WILL.
IF TRAE YOUNG IS NOT IN, LOU
WILL IS IN.
THERE'S NO REPLACEMENT FOR
GIANNIS.
THEY HAVE ANOTHER ANTETOKOUNMPO
BUT HE'S NO GIANNIS.
>> I AGREE.
>> I SEE GIANNIS AS THE MOST
VALUABLE PLAYER IF THE TEAM WAS
TO LOSE THAT PLAYER.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
I'M GIVING AWAY A HOODIE AND A
JERSEY.
I GOT WI SPORTS 414 SAYING THE
BUCKS WILL LOSE BY 10 POINTS
TONIGHT.
>> WOW.
>> TAKE THE WIN MARGIN.
>> YOU NEED TO KNOW, ERIN IS THE
PLUG AT FANDUEL.
I NEED THE PLUGS, THE WALL
PLUGS, ERIN IS THE PLUG AT
FANDUEL.
BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
I GOT NAMELESS IS ROCKING WITH
THE GIF, WITH THE JANUARGIANNIS.
THERE IT IS.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I THINK IT'S TIME TO GIVE AWAY A
JERSEY.
>> GIVE ONE OUT.
>> LET ME GIVE OUT A JERSEY.
I GOT BAD SPORTS TAKES.
ERIN, I WANT YOU TO KNOWS THERE
A LOT OF PLUGS IN THE COMMENTS.
THEY'VE SHOWING YOU LOVE.
I GOT BAD SPORTS TAKES, GIANNIS
IS THE GUY.
GIANNIS IS THE GUY NOT TO LOSE.
HE'S THE POWER OF THE TEAM.
IF MIDDLETON CAN'T BACK UP, THEN
YOU CAN'T REPLACE.
OKAY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOUR TAKE.
I'M GIVING THE JERSEY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU WALK AWAY WITH A JERSEY BAD
SPOTS TAKES.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
ERIN, I GOT LOTS MORE JERSEYS TO
GIVE AWAY.
LET'S GET TO THIS NEXT SEGMENT.
>> LET'S GET TO IT.
>> LET'S LOOK -- LET'S TAKE A
LOOK, ERIN, AT THE AUDIENCE'S
FAVORITE FIRST BASKET.
WHO WILL SCORE THE FIRST BASKET?
LET'S LOOK AT THE FIRST BASKET
ODDS.
THERE THEY ARE.
AWESOME ODDS.
TRAE AND MY BOY CLINT CAPELA
BOTH LISTED AS QUESTIONABLE
TODAY.
WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO, GET
IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHO
IS SCORING THE FIRST BASKET?
ERIN, ERIN, ERIN, WHO DO YOU
HAVE?
>> I LOVE THIS.
TO BE BLUNT, IT'S HARD TO HIT
THE FIRST BASKET SCORERS, MAYBE
IT'S ME.
I'M GOING WITH KHRIS MIDDLETON
PLUS 420, NOT BECAUSE IT'S THE
LOWEST ODDS AND TECHNICALLY MOST
LIKELY TO HAPPEN, BUT THE LAST
TIME I WAS ASKED THIS QUESTION
ON THE SHOW, I SAID MIDDLETON
AND IT HIT.
I'M BEING SUPERSTITIOUS AND
TAKING HIM AGAIN.
GREAT ODDS FOR THOSE WANTING TO
BET INTO THE FIRST BASKET SCORE
MARKET.
>> LET'S GO.
I'M GOING TO PIGGYBACK OFF OF
YOU.
ON SUNDAY I WAS ON NBA BET
STREAMS PRESENTED BY FANDUEL,
WHICH ERIN IS THE PLAN FOR.
I WAS ON NBA BET STREAMS, I TOOK
CLINT CAPELA TO SCORE THE FIRST
BASKET.
GUESS WHO SCORED?
>> CLINT CAPELA.
>> SO SINCE WE'RE BEING
SUPERSTITIOUS, SINCE WE'RE
PICKING PICKS THAT ALREADY WON,
I WILL FOLLOW YOU, ERIN.
I'LL ROCK WITH MY GUY, CLINT
CAPELA.
HE WAS AT THE BOTTOM OF THAT
LIST.
HE WAS AT THE BOTTOM PLUS 1,000.
SHOUT OUT TO CLINT CAPELA.
I'M RIDING WITH HIM TO SCORE THE
FIRST BUCKET.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
>> 10-1 THERE.
>> I LOVE VALUE.
I LOVE PLUS MONEY AND VALUE.
LET'S SEE WHO YOU GUYS ARE
RIDING WITH.
>> DEEK GEEKIS IN THE HOUSE.
HE'S RIDING WITH JOHN COLLINS.
>> GOOD ONE.
>> PLUS 1100.
DEEK GEEK YOU'RE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
AND RIP CITY, GOT TO GO WITH
LOPEZ, CORNER THREE FOR THE
FIRST BASKET.
>> INTERESTING ONE.
>> THOUGHING A CHANGEUP AT US
THERE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU RIP CITY,
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ERIN, THE PRODUCER WHISPERED
INTO MY EAR AND TOLD ME TO GIVE
AWAY A JERSEY.
>> GO FOR IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
THIS NEXT PERSON WILL WALK AWAY
WITH A JERSEY.
RICHIE 21.
RICHIE 21, FIRST BASKET WITHOUT
GIANNIS, HE WILL TRY TO GET IT
GOING EARLY.
HE GAVE US A GIF OF KHRIS
MIDDLETON.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN SEE IT.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> SORRY.
LET ME GET A LITTLE -- THERE IT
IS.
KHRIS MIDDLETON.
THERE IT IS.
ROCKING WITH KHRIS MIDDLETON.
SHOUT OUT TO RICHIE 21.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
ERIN, GUESS WHAT?
>> WHAT?
>> I GOT MORE JERSEYS TO GIVE
AWAY.
>> MORE?
>> LET'S KEEP MOVING.
WHY NOT.
>> THAT'S HOW WE GET PEOPLE
GOING IN THE COMMENTS.
>> OF COURSE.
THEY LOVE THE JERSEYS.
THEY LOVE THE HOODIES AND THE
VIBES.
AND THEY LOVE YOU, TOO.
>> ALWAYS GOOD VIBES.
>> SHOUT OUT TO THE PEOPLE.
LET'S GET ON.
I GOT MORE JERSEYS TO GIVE AWAY.
WE ASKED YOU ON SOCIAL AND IN
THE APP WHO IS THE TOP SCORER
FOR TONIGHT'S GAME?
HOW MANY POINTS WILL THEY HAVE?
WITH ALL THE INJURIES, THE ODDS
ARE NOT UP YET, BUT THEY WILL BE
UP BY GAMETIME.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL US
WHO DO YOU THINK WILL BE THE TOP
SCORER AND HOW MANY POINTS
THEY'RE GOING TO SCORE.
AT THE END OF THE GAME WE'LL DM
YOU.
ONE PERSON -- ONLY DM'ing ONE
PERSON WHO GUESSED CORRECTLY AND
HOOK YOU UP WITH A JERSEY.
TRAE IS A GAME-TIME DECISION
TONIGHT.
GAME-TIME DECISION.
GIANNIS IS OUT.
LOU WILL STEPPED UP.
HE CARRIED THAT HAWKS TEAM IN
GAME FOUR WITH 21 POINTS, 8
ASSISTS.
I TALKED ABOUT HIM EARLIER.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HIM NOW.
LOU WILL, MY GUY.
WHO DO YOU THINK WILL BE THE TOP
SCORER?
>> I THINK --
>> WITH THE TWO SUPERSTARS OUT
OF THE MIX.
I'M SORRY.
I HAD TO THROW THAT OUT THERE.
>> YOU'RE FINE.
>> THE TWO SUPERSTARS ARE OUT OF
THE MIX.
WHO ARE YOU TAKING?
>> I THINK THE TOP SCORER IS
GOING TO BE KHRIS MIDDLETON.
HE'S AVERAGING 21 POINTS IN THE
SERIES, WHICH IS LESS THAN TRAE
YOUNG WHO IS AVERAGING 33
POINTS.
WITH GIANNIS OUT OF THE GAME, I
THINK MIDDLETON HAS TO STEP UP
AS HE DID IN THE PREVIOUS SERIES
IN GAMES 3 AND 6.
EVEN LIKE HE PLAYED IN GAME
THREE IN ATLANTA WHEN HE LEAD
THE TEAM WITH 31 POINTS,
MIDDLETON HAS IT IN HIM AND
TONIGHT HAS TO BE HIS NIGHT IN
MILWAUKEE.
I WAS CONFLICTED WITH THIS
QUESTION, GREG, BECAUSE I
THOUGHT IT COULD BE MIDDLETON OR
TRAE YOUNG IF HE'S RULED IN.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THE HAWKS
KNOW GIANNIS IS OUT AND THEY WON
GAME FOUR WITHOUT TRAE, SO WHY
RISK HIS HEALTH?
AND IT'S NOT A DO OR DIE
SITUATION FOR EITHER TEAM
TONIGHT.
I'LL GO WITH SOMEBODY ON THE
BUCKS AND KHRIS MIDDLETON.
>> ERIN IS LOCKING IN KHRIS
MIDDLETON.
I WILL THROW A CURVEBALL AT
EVERYBODY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> EVERYBODY MIGHT MAKE FUN OF
ME OR TALK ABOUT ME, BUT I'M
GOING WITH DANILO GALLINARI.
HE LIKES THAT HIGH-ARCING SHOT.
TRAE IS QUESTIONABLE TO PLAY.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TRAE WILL
BRING TO THE TABLE.
DANILO.
I LUKE THE VIBES.
I'M PRETTY SURE HE'S GOING TO BE
HIGH ON THE LIST AS FAR AS IN
THE ODDS?
HE'S BEEN PLAYING WELL.
I LIKE TO ROLL THE DICE A BIT
AND ROCK WITH GALLINARI.
TAKING A LITTLE RISK.
THROWING A LITTLE DART.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS ON THE iPAD,
THE COMMENTS ARE MOVING REALLY
FAST.
I HAVE WINNIE THE POOH WHO SAYS
TRAE WITH 47.
ERIN, DID YOU WATCH WINNIE THE
POOH GROWING UP?
>> I DID.
WHEN I WAS BORN, MY ROOM WAS A
WHOLE WINNIE THE POOH THEME.
WALLPAPER AND ALL.
>> I ACTUALLY STUCK THE VHS
TAPE, I STUCK THE WINNIE THE
POOH VHS TAPE INTO MY VHS TAPE
RECORDER BECAUSE I PUT IT IN
BACKYARDS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU WINNIE THE
POOH, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMENTS IS
SAYING I HAD A BAD TAKE.
I STILL LOVE YOU.
IN THE COMMENTS, G. MONEY, EMIT
THE GOAT, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE JUST FOR SAYING MY
TAKE WAS FIRE.
I GOT SOMEBODY.
I GOT TO SHOW THE OTHER SIDE
SOME LOVE.
ENDERMAN AND WADE 0821.
G., YOU TRIPPING, GALLINARI
AIN'T GOING OFF.
YOU BOTH ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIEMENT
>> KEEPING YOU HUMBLE.
>> GOT TO STAY HUMBLE.
GOT TO STAY HONEST.
IT'S OKAY.
YOU GUYS WILL SEE, DANILO WILL
HAVE A GAME TONIGHT.
REMEMBER, PLEASE REMEMBER, WE'RE
GOING TO HIT ONE OF YOU GUYS UP
AFTER THE GAME AND HOOK YOU UP
WITH THE JERSEY.
I GOT ONE MORE, ERIN.
ONE MORE JERSEY TO GIVE AWAY IN
THIS LAST SEGMENT.
I'LL NEED GIFS.
THE GIFS IN THE COMMENTS, GIVE
ME THOSE FOR THIS NEXT ONE.
TO EVERYONE'S SURPRISE THIS
ATLANTA/MILWAUKEE SERIES IS TIED
2-2.
WE ASKED YOU ON TWITTER WHO IS
GOING TO WIN THIS SERIES?
WE ASKED YOU RIGHT THERE, TAGGED
YOU GUYS, FANDUEL SPORTS BOOK.
HERE ARE THE RESULTS.
OH.
>> KIND OF SURPRISED BY THIS.
62% OF PEOPLE REALLY SIDED WITH
ATLANTA.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE MORE
CLOSER TO 50%.
I GUESS NOT.
>> I'M PRETTY SURPRISED BY THIS,
TOO.
ERIN, THE LINE HAS MOVED A BIT
SINCE OUR POST.
LET'S LOOK AT THE LATEST ODDS.
LATEST ODDS.
THERE THEY ARE.
MINUS 120.
MINUS 120 NOW.
THE BUCKS ARE SLIGHTLY FAVORED.
>> YEAH.
>> THE HAWKS ARE NOW AT PLUS
MONEY.
LOOK AT FANDUEL.
THE GUYS AT FANDUEL HOOKING US
UP.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL US
WHICH TEAM IS BETTER TO WIN THE
SERIES, BUCKS OR IS IT THE
HAWKS?
YOU GUYS TELL ME WHICH TEAM IS
BETTER TO WIN THE SERIES,
BUCKS/HAWKS.
I NEED SOME GIFS IN THE
COMMENTS.
ERIN, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> FIRST OFF MY ADVICE FOR THOSE
LOOKING TO BET INTO THE SERIES
MARKET, BET IT NOW, BECAUSE
THESE SERIES PRICE ODDS CAN AND
WILL SHIFT DRASTICALLY AFTER
EACH GAME.
TO GET BACK TO YOUR QUESTION,
EVERY TIME I COUNT OUT THE
HAWKS, I AM PROVEN WRONG.
I WAS SHOCKED WHEN THEY BEAT THE
SIXERS, NOW I'M SURPRISED
THEY'RE IN THIS POSITION AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS, BUT --
A BIG BUT HERE, I THINK THE
BUCKS WILL PULL OFF SOME MAGIC.
I DON'T SAY THAT WITH TOO MUCH
CONFIDENCE BUT A POTENTIAL GAME
SEVEN AT HOME IN MILWAUKEE WILL
BE AN ADVANTAGE FOR THE TEAM.
I WILL GO WITH THE BUCKS MINUS
120 BECAUSE YOU WON'T SEE IT
PROBABLY AT THAT PRICE IF THEY
WIN TONIGHT.
>> ERIN IS ROCKING WITH THE
BUCKS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, ERIN.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
NOT ONLY AM I GIVING AWAY A
HOODIE BUT I'M GIVING A WAY A
JERSEY FOR THE FINAL TIME.
I HAVE -- FUNNY GIFS.
>> LET'S SEE SOME OF THE GIFS.
>> I GOT RHEMT M 21, JOHN
COLLINS, CROWN HIM RIGHT THERE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, RHET.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
JAY VELAZQUEZ 17.
GOING WITH THE FUNNY GIF OF THE
KID BEING SUPER EXCITED FOR THE
HAWKS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
SPORTS FEED IS ABOVE THEM.
YOU SEE THE BUCKS SLIDING IN.
HE SAYS THE BUCKS CRUISING FOR
THE WIN.
SEE THE BUCKS MASCOT UP THERE
CRUISING FOR THE WIN.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY I JUST
MENTIONED.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ERIN, I THINK IT'S TIME TO GIVE
OUT THE JERSEY.
>> GO FOR THE JERSEY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> LAST ONE.
>> THE JERSEY?
>> YEAH.
>> LAST ONE.
I GOT MY BOY, AMAN ZANEREZ,
KEVIN HUERTER TO HELP ATLANTA
WIN THE EAST.
LOOK AT THE GIF.
>> THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
>> THIS IS THE KID THAT SINGS
THE COUNTRY -- I FORGET HIS
NAME.
HE WENT VIRAL A COUPLE YEARS
AGO.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
THE TIME HAS COME.
>> YEAH.
>> THE TIME HAS COME.
THANKS FOR TAPPING IN TO THE
"GROUP CHAT" PRESENTED BY
FANDUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
THE 3x2 IS A LOCK.
BELIEVE IN THE SUNSET VIBES.
>> YES.
>> DANILO GALLINARI IS A SLEEPER
LOCK.
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMENTS, YOU
GUYS ARE ASLEEP.
I NEED THE SLEEP EMOJI IN THE
COMMENTS, THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE.
GET IN THERE AND BET YOUR SERIES
PICKS BEFORE THE LINES CHANGE.
GET IN THERE AND BET THOSE
PICKS.
WE'LL BE BACK.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT THURSDAY FOR
GAME ONE OF THE FINALS.
WE'RE GOING TO BE BACK FOR GAME
ONE OF THE FINALS.
GUESS WHAT?
WE'LL GIVE AWAY HOODIES.
WE'LL GIVE AWAY MORE JERSEYS.
SOMETHING EXTRA SPECIAL FOR THE
FINAL.
YOU GUYS HAVE TO TUNE IN AND
GUESS WHAT WE'RE GIVING AWAY.
IF YOU WANT A HOODIE, IF YOU
WANT A JERSEY, WE WILL DM YOU.
DON'T BE ALARMED.
ALONGSIDE ERIN DOLAN, I'M GREG
IVORY, WE'RE LEAVING THE "GROUP
CHAT."
PEACE.
>> SEE YA.
♪